hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast a keynote presentation
supporting precision medicine and
clinical research at scale challenges
and opportunities it is presented by
Nile Lenin PhD the senior director of
translational genomics and product
development and an institute scientist
at the Broad Institute of MIT and
Harvard I am Judy I work of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
lennon i will now turn the presentation
over to him thank you Judy so it's a
pleasure to be here to give this
presentation to you today the premise of
my title and my presentation is that
precision medicine is at an inflection
point moving from a concept at academic
medical centers to a reality across a
broad swath of the healthcare
environment and you know towards being
an accepted standard of care in several
areas but what is the evidence
for that are we is this true are we
really at a turning point there's
certainly a lot of news about it so I
want to dig in a little bit on whoa you
know how do we believe that this is true
and I guess to think about that we
really should think about how are we
defining precision medicine today what
does it mean to me I first really sort
of thought deeply about precision
medicine in the oncology space as many
people have and this review by Levi
Garraway at formerly of the Dana Farber
and the Center for cancer precision
medicine there in 2013 sort of summed it
up nicely for me about precision
oncology and really shows the thinking
at the time which was that molecular
profiling of a patient's tumor could
lead to understanding of individual drug
regimens that that patient might
particularly respond to or might inform
clinical trials of that patient could be
enrolled it or could be prognostic of a
patient's outcome and so this was this
was really for me sort of that you know
started to think about this personalized
precision we moved from the definition
of personalized medicine to precision
medicine using genomic molecular
profiling to help guide therapeutic
choices or patient involvement in the
you know five years or so that have that
have followed that we've seen tremendous
activity in this space and several
companies have now launched and received
FDA approval for genomic profiling tests
some more notable ones are the
foundation medicine test and the uncle
mine test from thermo Fisher so these
tests have received FDA approval now as
companion diagnostics which allows them
this genomic profile to be used to help
assign people to particular treatments
and more recently we're actually seeing
CMS Center for Medicare and Medicaid
Services issue some coverage guidelines
for this type of testing this really as
we start to see reimbursement for this
type of testing this really moves it
from the self payer
access model to really more broad
widespread adoptions that's certainly a
good indicator for the field and
adoption another indicator is that we
see healthcare systems start to launch
projects and programs to make this type
of testing more broadly available the VA
Veterans Administration is one such
program that's recently announced it is
expanding some pilots that they've done
in precision oncology to make this type
of testing available to all of their
clinical sites and this is a as one of
the largest healthcare systems in the
country this is a large move towards the
adoption of this type of testing just
last week however there has been some
notes of caution we have to be very
careful according to this editorial in
nature last week about over hyping the
types of personalized treatments that
can be assigned based on precision
medicine testing we're all aware of the
great cases of immune checkpoint
inhibitors literally melting away
patients tumors however there is much
research still to be done about what
patients will respond to such treatments
what patients become resistant to such
treatments and the mechanisms underlying
both of those scenarios and so
overselling a promise of precision
medicine too soon could also be very
detrimental to the field so that's a
that's a challenge that we need to be
cognizant of of course you know we all
sort of thought of precision medicine
mostly in the cancer space in the last
couple of years however this is now
really moving into the more common
disease non cancer space as well one
program that really challenges us to
think about precision medicine at scale
is the all of us research program this
is NIH --is program formerly known as
the precision medicine initiative and so
really this seeks to enroll up to 1
million participants across the United
States in the next five years and do
genomic profiling of everybody and from
this million person cohort there will be
many many many research things that can
be done including understanding the
relationship
between genetic risk factors and certain
diseases being able to monitor because
leaders association that clinical
records monitor responds to different
types of treatments enroll people in
clinical studies for different disease
types this is a very valuable cohort
going forward and there is a an element
of return results to each individual
participant here so each person can use
the genomic information that's being
generated in some way so this is again a
definition of personalized or precision
medicine in action at scale I should say
on a personal note I've enrolled in the
all of us research program it is open to
everybody all of us and so blood
collection sample collection clinical
checkup very simple I did locally at
Mass General and I recommend anybody
who's interested in getting genomic data
about themselves enroll in in the all of
us research program of course there have
been some commercial companies launched
in the last couple of years who are
really providing access to precision
genomic information to individuals
probably some of the more famous ones
are listed here 23andme of course folks
know direct-to-consumer genetic testing
allowing people to understand many
attributes about themselves including
not just ancestry but also risks for
developing certain diseases companies
like in vitae and color genomics are
providing very focused testing for
particular risk factors in certain
diseases and recent studies have shown
that this direct-to-consumer genetic
testing is likely to continue to grow
over the next couple of years and again
this is scalable genetic testing with
the purpose of providing personalized
information to folks to make health care
and lifestyle lifestyle choices so this
is exciting
there are non-commercial activities in
this space as well some one example of
this is the company in program that's
run from the Broad Institute and this
actually seeks to find and enroll
patients from particular disease type up
who have a particular disease into
research studies and to really change
the paradigm about how enrollment on
clinical research studies is done
typically historically this would have
been done at the local hospital level
when a certain patient presents with a
particular disease somebody a clinical
coordinator asks them if they want to
enroll in a research study and this has
been the model across the country for
for many many years
um what the researchers realize is that
if you're studying particular subsets of
patients those are may be patients with
metastatic breast cancer who have a
particular response exceptional response
to some drugs or on the other side
people who become resistant to their
treatments you really want to study
these mechanisms as I said before but in
a one single Hospital you likely don't
see enough patients even at a large
Hospital in these subsets to do rigorous
robust scalable research and so the Kami
and project allows participants to
enroll from around the country
metastatic breast cancer project was the
one of the first and most widely adopted
of these types of projects this project
has now enrolled over 4,500 men and
women with metastatic breast cancer from
all 50 states in the United States and
these folks have logged on to the NBC
project org website largely this you
know information about this study is
passed through social media events for
patient groups and a word-of-mouth and
so people log on when they log on they
essentially fill out questionnaires they
give consent for the researchers to look
at their medical records and they give
consent for the researchers to contact
their primary doctors or their local
hospital to receive to request some of
their tumor biopsy material if it exists
and they also received saliva tubes just
from us just as they would if as if
they'd signed up with 23 me or one of
the other direct - patient genomic
testing companies and we use that saliva
we collect as the sort of match
normal material to compare against that
patients tumor and this helps us to do
better higher sensitivity mutation
calling of their tumor and so this
molecular profiling then on every
patient allows us to identify subsets of
patients and do the underlying research
so this is a really sort of great
paradigm for enrolling large sets of
patients to do really meaningful
research and so we see again in the
going forward we see a lot more
involvement of individual participants
they're no longer just anonymous
faceless patient cohorts now these are
really each patient is invested in their
own disease and their research and they
feel like in some small ways they can
contribute and they are making a large
contribution through the research that
may help even if it doesn't help them
can help future generations of folks
with these diseases so this is a very
worthwhile sort of paradigm shifting
approach to sort of personalized
involvement in in research of course
once we get into this precision
personalized world of genetic testing
for everybody we can learn all kinds of
things about ourselves that maybe don't
fall into the precision medicine bucket
that we originally thought we would be
in there are several groups now who
allow sort of direct to genomic
direct-to-consumer genomic testing for
lifestyle information and biome is one
example here of a group who'll tell you
about your wine preferences based on
your genetic makeup this is precision
something and we know totally valid but
also as we as we as we you know expand
testing testing make it cheaper make it
broadly available to everybody there's
all kinds of things you can learn not
just relating to our health another
metric we may use is who are the big
winners on a technology side and so
Illumina many of us are familiar with as
one of the major technology providers
for genomic and genetic testing both on
the genotyping array platforms which a
lot of the 23andme and others use
and the next generation or massively
parallel sequencing field which is used
in in larger genomic studies and so you
know a reflection on the growth of that
company over the last couple of years
can really help us look at wow something
is changing we are the the community is
certainly growing the market is
certainly grow okay maybe a non
scientific piece of evidence um about
the state of this field I am really
really busy why is that a good marker of
anything well that really has to do with
what I do and where I sit so some people
may be familiar with the Broad Institute
if you're not it's a large nonprofit
institution in Kendall Square Cambridge
outside Boston and our mission is to
transform medicine using systematic
approaches the biological sciences to
accelerate the understanding and
treatment of disease the way the Broad
is is structured is that we have
research programs that are focused on
particular disease areas including
cancer vectors disease population and
medical genetics psychiatric disease and
others and then we have large-scale
technology platforms who build
infrastructure and processes at scale to
serve all of the various disease areas
and so it is within the genomics
platform at Road that I sit the genomics
group at Road encompasses a largest
single group probably over 200
individuals now and expands everything
from wet lab you know sample saliva
blood sample receipt through sample
preparation data generation on
sequencing platforms or array genotyping
platforms primary analysis base calling
secondary analysis variant calling from
this data and and then various ways to
present and how data share data across
researchers whose data at a in a
scalable way and we'll talk a little bit
about that later
so I'm within the genomics group then
the genomics platform is the data
generation powerhouse here we
encompasses over a hundred folks and
sits on you know one of the larger
install bases of massively parallel
sequencing platforms in the country with
largely an Illumina centric fleet but
this actually allows us to undertake
very large projects and so broad is
probably known among those who know it
for the scale of the projects that are
undertaken here you know dating back all
the way to the precursor projects from
the founding of the institution that the
human genome project through large-scale
data generation projects four thousand
genomes the Cancer Genome Atlas TCGA the
human microbiome project all the way
through you know things that are ting
just starting up now the human cell
access for single cell sequencing across
many different cell types and so this
has really driven data generation across
a number of different essay types here
as you can see in the graphs here we
really sort of seen exponential growth
in the last couple of years in the
amount of data we've been producing
largely driven by the increase in the
number of old human genomes human
genomes that we've been sequencing we
just recently sequenced our hundred
thousand human genome let's take a
moment to absorb that the first human
genome project that was done here in
collaboration with many groups around
the world took around 13 to 15 years to
get a draft done cost about three
billion dollars now we're producing
hundreds of human genomes every single
day for a cost around a thousand dollars
so that's been really part of this
genomics revolution that underlies the
application you know the translation now
of this field into healthcare and
medicine we've also done over a million
of the genotyping arrays that allow for
risk status genome-wide Association
studies exilim sequencing you know
there's a method that has been developed
at the Broad has been applied here over
350,000 times we also do large amounts
of RNA sequencing gene panel sequencing
and I know other things
what may be less well known about the
road is that we actually also have a
clinical sequencing arm we a couple of
years ago created a clinical research
sequencing platform or Chris and this
platform is a clear cap compliant lab
that allows us to do clinical sequencing
it was always designed to be relatively
small-scale to start and really serving
the clinical research community that we
interact with here with our local
hospital groups and across the country
and so we've done around 15,000 cynical
samples in in our clinical lab here that
across some small number of tests that
include germline and somatic whole exome
sequencing we have a one non sequencing
based test actually for a rare kidney
disease and we've done many custom gene
panels for cancer and germline
sequencing as well and as of March 1st
we've actually just launched a CLIA
whole human genome sequencing test as
well for germline medications again
largely it's not really our mission to
be a send out diagnostic testing lab
we're really here to support
translational studies and so we've done
that over the last few years supporting
over 14 different clinical trials
ranging from small investigator trials
at local hospitals one that is very much
along the lines of precision medicine is
a trial around the development of
personalized can seen cancer vaccines
for patients and that's recently been
published as well as some you know
publicly released information around
major pharmaceutical companies that
we've worked with to help with their
clinical trials as well so what are
people talking to us about right now you
know why why am I so busy well people
are talking to us about developing lots
of different things in lots of different
areas but I thought maybe two particular
case studies could be useful to
illustrate where we're at in the field
and we could be going and so these case
studies really are
one on the cancer side we'll talk a
little bit about liquid biopsy and one
on the on the germline side or clinical
human genome sequencing so many folks
are probably familiar with liquid biopsy
for cancer at this point to summarize
you know traditional biopsies have
really been around surgical resection or
fine needle aspiration of tumor material
and from that we've you know the
traditional paradigm and pathology has
been to do formal in fixation paraffin
embedding or you know histological
examination and so a lot of the archived
uneven you know new tumor material we
get are in the form of FFPE slides these
can be challenging of course as we know
for genomic testing there are also the
ability to collect fresh frozen tissue
as well and that that can be much much
easier to work with from a genomics
perspective however in the last couple
of years we've seen a really a large
groundswell in interest in collecting
liquid biopsy so this is you know
traditionally today we're talking about
peripheral blood collection although
there is work on on urine collection as
well and so obviously the benefits of
being able to work from peripheral blood
is that it is cheaper and far less
invasive to the patient and it is
possible to continue to collect
peripheral blood even after a patient
may have had a tumor removal in which
curative intent this one may be allows
us to monitor patients post-surgery for
any residual cancer or metastatic cancer
so the challenges of course over the
last couple of years have been how do we
from peripheral blood examine or
genomically characterize a patient's
tumor and so there's been a ton of work
in the field to show that we can extract
from blood analytes that actually
reflect the tumor and these analyte
should be
in the form of circulating tumor cells
which they maybe three or four years ago
had a lot of attention and then more
recently that's shifted actually to
cell-free circulating tumor DNA and you
know the reason that the shift has
happened - maybe cell-free has been
around again the ease of collection it's
a specific extraction protocol as
opposed to circulating tumor cells where
you need more specialized equipment to
capture those cells and then you're
dealing with a very small number of
cells that you need to do specialized
molecular biology on so a lot of focus
has been on cell free DNA in in recent
years there's been a large activity at
the broad research group in our cancer
program that's been looking at that and
has developed some strategies for
looking at blood derived CF DNA and
there's a paradigm that we're working on
now which is collection and extraction
of CF DNA from whole blood and then
application of ultra low pass whole
genome sequencing as this is genome
sequencing at the less than 1 1 X
coverage of the entire genome from that
we've developed analytical methods to be
able to estimate the amount of
circulating tumor cell in that CF DNA
sample based on the amount of material
there the sample then may be suitable
for differing downstream genomic assays
if you have a large amount of
circulating tumor you know greater than
10 percent you could do whole exome
sequencing or whole genome sequencing if
you're in the 1 to 10 percent range then
it's more suitable for a deeper gene
panel type sequencing essay and then if
you have very rare very low levels you
may need an additional Zoar a very
personalized type of assay and this is
just information from a publication
recently from Victor Edelstein 'some
who's led that cancer program research
group at Barone and on the Left we're
seeing in the top two panels here the
you know close correlation between ultra
low pass or 0.1 x
whole genome sequencing and a more
traditional deeper genome sequencing
from the same patient and what we're
looking at here is a copy number profile
across the entire genome and what you
can see is that the copy number spikes
the amplifications and deletions mirror
exactly between the ultra low pass or
the deeper genome sequencing and from
these we can estimate tumor fraction and
you can see the tumor fraction
estimations is exactly the same in this
case on the same patient and the bottom
two pounds we're also seeing that even
at 1x of that same patient from the
tumor now not from the circulating free
DNA we're seeing obviously we've got a
higher tumor fraction because now we're
biopsy the tumor directly and we see
correlation between genome sequencing
and whole exome sequencing of that tumor
in the copy number profile and all of
this is from one patient and so you can
see across the CF DNA and the solid
tumor we see the same pattern of copy
number and in the very low pass whole
genome were able to see this pattern and
we're able to estimate tumor fraction in
that CF DNA so this is a very powerful
technique that allows us to triage
incoming blood samples or to understand
what what type of downstream assay is
most suitable and also what samples are
likely to succeed in what samples will
not and this is important as an
acceptance criteria if we move this to a
clinical testing paradigm on the right
hand side here we're seeing then looking
at matched tumor and CF DNA genetic
alterations in a group of patients and
we see really good on average
correlation between the variants found
in the tumor and in the circulating free
DNA this is important as well if you
want to make inferences about a
patient's tumor from whole blood to get
technical for a moment you know we've
over the last year and our R&D group
spent a long time understanding how to
better access these very low amounts of
circulating free DNA and the even
smaller amounts of CT DNA we get we
haven't talked about it yet but from
whole blood or plasma we may often only
get 5 to 20
grams of material act this is a very
small amount to start any kind of
genetic testing from or genomic sample
prep and so and within that five or 20
nanograms only a subset of that will be
the tumor DNA and so you really need
methods that allow you to do to have one
a very high conversion efficiency of
input molecules to final sequence symbol
molecules and also we need to because we
have to amplify these molecules to
sequence them we need to incorporate
methods that allow us to distinguish
duplicate molecules from unique
molecules and to be able to do variant
calling with high sensitivity and low
allele fraction and so there's a lot of
requirements on both the molecular
biology and the analytical side that
need to to happen to make that really
work well and one of the tricks that
we've seen that works the best is
actually switching to a this dual Y
adapter with dual indexes and dual um
eyes unique molecular indexes that's
very important for downstream calling
we've you know obviously ideally you do
that you'd apply you'll be able to do
development on many many patient samples
but because of the scarcity and valuable
nature of real patient samples we've
created synthetic models of lowly
refraction events by taking healthy
donors so healthy individuals actually
have circulating free DNA it does is not
tumor DNA but it's it's cell free DNA
and so we if we take two unrelated
donors and spike one persons CF DNA into
the other we can artificially create a
model that looks like a CT DNA at
varying levels and there then we can
characterize many variants within within
that set depending on the on the
territory that we sequence and from that
calculate our sensitivity and our
specificity and so there's a lot of work
ongoing here but one you know one result
we can share here that is illustrative
of the types of things that we have to
optimize for using traditional adapt
library adapter systems we were seeing
very high false positive
and that's illustrated in these Lego
plots if you haven't seen a lego plot
this essentially just shows all of the
different variant types within a given
sample and the base context in which
that variant type is seen this plot is
very useful that you're looking for a
particular type of artifact and you're
sequencing you know things that have
been seen say SPE samples but
illustrative here is that the height of
the of the bars and this negative plot
are telling us that there's a lot of
false positives in our data when we use
traditional library construction methods
when we switch to our you know latest
you know duplex dual you my adapter
methods that have been published by many
groups now we see that this actually
coupled with our analysis methods
drastically reduces the number of false
positives and this is very very
important when you're doing genetic
testing especially in the clinic because
we really want to be able to extract
real meaningful signal from false
positives that will send you down the
wrong path so that's just that's not a
really quick overview of some of the
things we've been doing in blood biopsy
and many groups are doing this same type
of work and so some of the challenges
here and considerations for widespread
adoption of this method are
understanding at the very the pre
analytical steps if we want to do liquid
biopsy based testing on patients we we
have to start to think about the process
at the collection point so how are we
collecting the sample how much sample
are we collecting is it possible to
collect two tubes of blood instead of
one and give us more molecules going in
which gives us higher complexity
libraries which gives us better
sensitivity the types of tubes we're
collecting the blood and is important if
we're collecting in traditional types of
you know EDTA tubes then the blood has
to be fractionated rapidly to avoid
degradation of the CF DNA there are
specialized tubes that you can use to
collect collect blood that makes it more
suitable for downstream CF DNA
extraction and so that needs to be
adopted you know we also need to think
about what I talked about the sample
prep and the analytical methods and how
we scale those across you know many
different gene panels that people want
to use now in different tumor types
and so this is something that we we were
thinking about actively here and then of
course we have this sort of the more at
the hotter level understanding the real
clinical utility of this type of testing
you know many groups have shown this
high concordance between a CF DNA and
tumor biopsy but what level of
concordance is required to really be
clinically useful and what can we do
from these studies and so clinical
utility studies are really where we're
at right now and across a lot of
different groups to understand the
different utilities whether it's
diagnostic prognostic or in monitoring
minimal residual disease in patients
post-surgery so very active area across
in the cancer space
so switching gears thinking about you
know more on the common disease side the
German germline Mendelian disease side
thinking about whole human genome
sequencing it's really only been in the
last few years that we could contemplate
human genome sequencing whole human
genome sequencing at scale previously
we've been largely doing panels or
exomes and that's largely been driven by
cost but as the technology platforms
have advanced in terms of yields per
cost per cost of those yields we've been
able to drive down the cost of
sequencing and that really has increased
adoption initially in the research space
to generate data for us to work from but
now increasingly into the clinical space
I think there may be a perception and by
some folks who aren't in the trenches
that now you know Oh genome sequencing
is just a solved problem anybody can do
it you just buy a box of alumina and
you're good to go and I really like this
quote from you and Bernie who's the
director of the European by Max
Institute on Twitter a few months ago
about genome sequencing and comparing it
to say it's routine in the same way that
the u.s. Navy routinely lands planes on
aircraft carriers yes a good organized
crew does it routinely but it is complex
and surprisingly easy to screw up and I
know having done 100,000 of the of these
genomes here we can tell you that it is
still a complex process and can go wrong
and
in many ways and we've seen a lot of
those ways here and so from that
experience in research we've been able
to take that process and make it
suitable for clinical clinical use to do
that we've taken our research pipeline
and gone through the process of making
it clear compatible and you know for
folks who've gone through that this is
really about addressing your process
your people your equipment every part of
the end and infrastructure establishing
analytical and technical validity of the
method documenting it and making sure
that you can do it robustly reproducibly
that's what we've gone through that and
like I said in March we launched our
whole genome we took our research whole
genome process and we made it from March
1 it could be used for CLIA purposes
also of course as you're doing that and
you have to make some decisions and one
of the things that people who are doing
clinical whole genome sequencing still
discussed is well how what how much
sequencing should you do what depth of
coverage of the genome is meaningful and
this is a continuing debate and how we
measure coverage is not necessarily
standardized this is one of the
challenges across the community and then
how what is good enough coverage is
another debate in the community that
needs to be sort of standardized or
harmonized for widespread adoption why
you see here is really just a quick
snapshot of understanding the
relationship between on the right-hand
panel here you know mean coverage of the
genome so a lot of folks think about you
know a default human genome being a 30x
human genome that's been a number that's
being used in research for a long time
other groups would say to be clinical
you read to be more of a 40 X genome or
a 45 X genome you know couple of points
there one point being that just mean
coverage as a single metric is probably
not the right metric for us all to use
in the community because just looking at
one number like coverage can be
misleading you can have 30 or 35 X
coverage of a genome mean coverage but
have very uneven coverage within the
genome so you really need to think about
evenness of the genome and one way to
account for that is actually thinking
about the
percentage or proportion of your genome
that's covered to a particular target
coverage and so one metric we've looked
at here is what is the percentage of our
genome that's at least covered a 20x
coverage we know from variant calling
statistics that a 20x coverage at a
given base you are well powered to call
at least a single nucleotide variant at
that base and so percent at 20x
encompasses coverage not just across the
acne on the average coverage across the
genome but actual situational coverage
or evenness of that coverage across the
entire genome and what we see is that
you know in in our clinical validation
study our target has really been a
minimum of 95 percent of the genome
covered of 20x what we on average see is
that we're really getting closer to 97.5
or 98% of the genome covered at at least
20 x and that correlates to a mean
coverage somewhere in the you know 35 to
40 range and so that's typically what
our genome looks like and here we can
see the relationship between that those
coverages and sensitivity the blue line
is for smv sensitivity in the orange
line for indoor sensitivity and of
course you can see that going you know
going to higher coverage gives you
higher you know
yields or returns on sensitivity for
particular variant types but then you
also have to balance cost so cost is a
huge factor in applying any kind of
genetic testing at scale and so we we're
in this area of balancing performance
and cost and again this is somewhere
where we need to decide on the right
targets across the community one way to
think about that is you know and taking
a subset of clinically meaningful genes
and saying well how did these genes
perform at your target coverages ACMG 59
has been something that has been thrown
around a lot and is also being used in
the all of us program ACMG 59 refers to
a set of 59 genes defined by the
American College of medical genetics as
genes that
have important findings for a patient so
oftentimes these are known as incidental
findings or secondary findings
returnable findings but these are genes
like brca1 or you know genes associated
with currently up with the heart disease
particular diseases that if you find
pathogenic variants in these genes in
the course of your genetic testing the
the ACMG recommends that you you inform
the patient about this and there's a lot
of debate and individual clinics and
health care centers about what's but to
return what to consent people for but
these particular variants are important
and so looking at how do we perform on
these genes not just at coverage but we
then looked at call ability as a
different metric and this is an a metric
or a modification version of a metric
that's been proposed by you and Ashley
of Stanford to look at an individual
base and say that the base is callable
that is you could call a variant at this
site in a more stringent way of saying
if it's covered at at least 20 X
coverage it has a mapping quality of Q
20 that means you're 99.9% sure that
that we'd matched that part of the
genome there's many parts of the genome
that are look very similar and so
sequencing reads could be placed at
multiple sites so you want to be
confident that your read is at the right
site and the base quality that is you
are confident again 99.9 percent
confident or greater that that the
individual base that you call at that
site is correct and so applying all
three of these criteria we can come up
with a call ability metric and we're
looking within the ACMG 59 we looked at
all of the bases in those genes and said
you know how we how are we doing for
call ability on these genes and if we
saw you know greater than 20% of our
cohort not having a callable days at a
given site we say that base is not
callable even though many of them could
be could be called but this is a quite a
stringent criteria and so looking at
ACMG 59 again there's approximately
16,000 or so pathogenic or likely
pathogenic variants in this gene set
according to one of the more well-known
basis of pathogenic variants of clinvar
and we looked at those all of those
variants and found that of the 16,000
only 20 or so were deemed not callable
by our stringent criteria and therefore
in this genome that's between 30 and 40
X we're covering over 99.9% of the
pathogenic variants in this in this set
so that's one measure of quality again
you know there's a lot of debate that in
the community and we need to come up
with standards to decide what we believe
should be the right metric and what the
should target should be so and you know
one thing to think about as well is
there are several challenges now and
considerations for widespread widespread
clinical adoption of whole genome
sequencing you know like I said even up
until recently it was cost prohibitive
now we're seeing a trajectory towards it
not being cost prohibitive when we
compare it to exon sequencing or gene
panel testing but but we need to realize
those costs we need to operate at scale
and so we need to ensure this clinical
grade quality at scale to serve the
entire patient population and so we've
lots of case studies now in many case
studies now in the community of
individual patients who've had maybe
long diagnostic Odysseys of individual
gene testing where whole genome
sequencing has found the answer and
there's lots of you know reports the
diagnostic yield of genome sequencing
versus exome sequencing versus
individual gene testing there's also
been you know demonstrations of we could
do genomes very fast 24 hours from blood
draw to data back and in some context
that could be important but but really
to be transformative we need to do we
need to do this at high quality and at
scale and at a cost that a healthcare
system can afford or can bear and so you
know one offs or you know demonstrations
of speed can be done that can be quite
expensive and so we need to think about
how do we scale this how do we do it
we reproducibly and robustly and that's
something that we've obviously thought
about here
a lot then you know as you do this at
scale you were really talking about
generating a lot of data whole genome
sequencing generates a lot of data
traditionally you know individual
sequencing sites would have store that
data locally or on-prem that just
becomes not feasible when you start to
think about whole genome sequencing just
the cost of storage and compute it
becomes quickly unmanageable for almost
all all institutions and so we really
need to understand where we host the
data how we do compute on this data in a
cost-efficient way and also you know
getting away from the traditional
paradigm of where you know if you did a
research study and you wanted to
collaborate on some analyses your
collaborators would just download or
copy your data and do their analysis as
we get to these very very large data
sets moving the data around copying the
data they come sort of non-trivial and
really is sort of the inefficient way to
do it and so we you know and others have
been looking at ways to create
environments where you can store the
data and bring the researchers through
the data or bring the clinicians to the
data as opposed to distributing the data
we also need to think about in the
future how much data do we need to keep
you know is the raw data important if we
start this as a clinical test what do we
define as the data that we must keep for
several years is it the raw data is it
the variants that we've determined from
that data is it the report that's been
created from those variants raw data you
know we used to keep in earlier versions
of the Illumina platforms we used to
keep image files that's become untenable
we don't keep image files anymore we now
we keep the base calls how long is it
before we decide that maybe even keeping
the base calls is no longer critical a
big open debate in the community and
something that we we need to all sort of
think about and I think about methods
for addressing so at the broad of course
we've built a platform for this
we've also you know we're also known for
some of the software tools the genome
analysis toolkit that we've made
available on that
cloud environment the type of
environment is called fire cloud and
we've done that on both to serve both
the concert community and now the genome
community data we sequence here both for
research and clinical is made available
through fire cloud and we think that's
where you know our futures or clinical
data delivery will be okay so so we've
covered a lot of different things here
on the cancer side the germline side I
think you know clearly there's massive
opportunity for the community at large
to use genomic testing and have it
improve patient outcomes in the cancer
space by indicating more you know
therapies or treatments that are more
likely to succeed or to allow better
more rational design of clinical trials
to get newer treatments ahead faster and
on the German side it's an opportunity
to really at scale understand you know
risks for for diseases and underlying
mechanisms of the diseases when we when
we do very large numbers for common
diseases we need to look at very very
large numbers of patients and we need to
look at patients from across all types
of different ethnic backgrounds because
inferring you know pathogenicity or
frequency of particular variants when
looking at just one and you know one
ethnic background is not helpful and so
one of the things we hope the all of us
research program will do is actually
increase our knowledge base of frequency
of common and rare variants in across
different types of backgrounds and that
will also give us power to address and
common diseases going forward as well
okay that's a lot so not you maybe you
understand a little bit of why I'm so
busy and because I think about all of
this all day long
so finally I just want to make thank you
all for listening to this hopefully you
kind of interesting if you have
questions about sequencing projects or
anything you would like to do with the
Broad Institute you can email us at
genomics up Road Institute org and there
are of course this endeavor is really
built on a foundation of many hundreds
of folks who work here who provide this
high-quality data
I think use do to you all of them as
well
thank you okay thank you dr. Lennon for
that informative presentation we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button well answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for so let's get started our first
question is can you discuss how a group
might decide between sequencing a gene
panel and exome or genome for both
cancer or non cancer studies yes so this
is something that comes up a lot and you
know ideally we would say it's all about
what gives you the scientifically best
answer but in many cases it also is
driven by cost and so on the non cancer
side you know really cost has driven us
to do exome sequencing and gene panel
sequencing in the last you know five ten
years and but what we're seeing now is
that as I described with the
technological advancements we're getting
whole genome sequencing down to a place
where it could start to cross over
certainly initially with exome
sequencing and maybe at some point with
with panel sequencing to be
cost-competitive and we know that the
data quality for germline purposes of a
PCR free well genome is just far
superior to anything that you'll do that
really that has a selection step or an
amplification step because of the
inherent biases that are introduced when
you do selection or PCR on the cancer
side it's a little bit different you
know for cancer because of the you know
stromal contamination of non cancer
cells in any kind of tumor biopsy or the
circulating free DNA that's not CT DNA
in a liquid biopsy the proportion of
your molecules that come from the tumor
are always lower and so you need
to be able to have power to call
variants and those that tumor DNA so you
need to go deeper and so there because
you need to go really deep that's really
pushed the cancer space to panel
sequencing to allow us to do far deeper
sequencing on a smaller territory again
cost-efficient we are starting to see
some some genome sequencing in the
cancer space and in again what genome
sequencing gives you in this context is
the ability to address different types
of structural variation that are really
hard to address from from panels things
like structural and large events in
genome so so right now in germline I see
I see a shorter term shift in some
settings to genomes in the cancer role I
see panels being sort of the way to go
for at least for the short to mid-term
thank you for that
what about interpretation and return of
genetic results and what will be needed
for this to scale right yeah this is a
huge thing and we didn't have time to
get into it today I think again when we
work with academic medical centers we
sort of take it for granted that we have
access to genetic counselors and we have
access to genetic fellows who can do
interpretation and molecular
pathologists who can interpret this type
of data but really for bright widespread
adoption what we need is really large
scale training programs to train cohorts
of genetic counselors who can return
these kinds of results explain these
complicated results to folks and
training of physicians and healthcare
providers to also be able to understand
them and there are many platforms and
companies now who are working on
creating reports that are more
understandable but also we need training
and harmonization across the community
on the meaning of some you know some
variants even in the germline community
different groups who interpret a
particular variant might interpret it
differently some might interpret it as a
benign variant doesn't doesn't do
anything some may say it's likely
pathogenic it actually might be causing
the disease so harmonization of those
these across different clinical sites is
very important as well what is the
biggest challenge facing precision
medicine today rain so so there are lots
of challenges obviously a lot of what I
think about are the technical challenges
the implementation challenges how we
develop the methods to give us the best
possible data how we deliver and manage
that data but across healthcare systems
of course it's really an adoption
question about cost how do we how do we
get the cost so we're not just adding to
the you know crazy cost of health care
already and to do that how we
demonstrating utility so how can we show
that if you spend the money on genome
sequencing you're saving money over the
course of a patient's life by not having
to do multiple individual genetic tests
later on so that clinical utility and
cost benefit analysis is ongoing in many
groups and that's really I think one
major thing that has to happen and the
other is on that technical side how do
we scale the testing and then how do we
integrate the results of the testing
into medical records and into a way that
can be absorbed and understood by
healthcare providers thank you we have
time for one more question how long
before we are sequencing everybody at
birth yeah that's that's that's that's
that's interesting future prospect right
and so I'm conflicted on this myself
we've been part of studies that one
study out of Harvard and Brigham
Hospital called baby seek and this
actually does do in a small cohort
sequencing of babies from healthy babies
and babies from the NICU sick babies and
and the study itself is really to
address this exact issue well one of
these issues around what is the utility
of that what do you learn could you do
something for the sick babies what is
the benefit to the healthy babies and
what is the process of actually
consenting people for that that's an
ongoing study
I'm very interesting and I think you
know from a purely scientific side
could see a benefit of of sequencing
very early to identify risk factors for
diseases that might be childhood early
onset diseases that you would want to
know about or later onset diseases that
could be you know risks could be
ameliorated through lifestyle choices or
more frequent screening that could
certainly be a benefit I think to get to
that point we really have to address
some significant concerns about privacy
genetic privacy security of your data
you know how do you keep that you know
very very personal data secure and
policy you know what right now we do
have a genetic non-discrimination Act
that says insurers can't refuse coverage
based on genetic profiling information
but but laws can be changed and so what
is the protection in the future for
somebody who has that type of testing
done so these are these are big sort of
ethical legal and social issues that
again many groups are looking at but
will be very soon to see how it plays
out few years well I would like to once
again thank dr. Lennon for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through September 21st 2018 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event that
is all for now thank you for joining us
we hope to see you again soon goodbye